please for those watching you may have
had your child come home from school
tell you there was a fight on top of it
that it was captured on video as madison
kimbrough reports it's a concern for
students and teachers many now voicing
their opinion
after talking to students and staff it's
clear that fighting at our schools
across the valley has escalated and for
many they have reached their breaking
point every time somebody threatens me
saying that they're going to beat me up
or pull up this is not okay and it's not
safe that was ccsd student lauren gomez
at the school board meeting thursday she
along with other students and staff
raising safety concerns over violent
behavior on campus and a teacher who did
not want to be identified told me the
problem is getting worse this year
there's been more fights than i've ever
seen this year than in my whole 24 years
at it all together a student here at
spring valley high school shared with me
some of the brawls they've witnessed
just this past week there was actually
another fight that happened i think
yesterday or wednesday
that was between two males so this was
right after lunch going into our next
class so she said if anyone's out
watching the fight get to class unless
you want to be pepper sprayed the same
sentiment by a canyon springs high
school teacher in a statement sent to 8
news now teachers office staff and
students do not feel safe students have
been bringing weapons with them on a
daily basis for protection at our school
there's been at least four times where
police had to use pepper spray on kids
in the cafeteria for lunch reporting
near buffalo and twain madison kimbrough
live local now so we reached out to the
school district for an accurate number
in terms of violent altercations
reported for this academic year we've
been told data will be released next
week we'll report it for you